[APPLAUSE]
JANA MOUDRA: Hi.
I'm so much excited to be
here and to talk about Dart.
I'm Jana Moudra,
and today I would
love to show you how we can
build an app using a Dart
and Firebase.
So before I start,
I will show you
or I will tell you who am I. I'm
from Prague in Czech Republic.
I have there a company
called Juicymo, where we
do mobile and app development.
And I'm also a Google
Developer expert for Dart
because I love to
talk about Dart.
And last but not
least, I'm a teacher
at a university because I
love to teach and to teach
developers.
So today I would
love to show you
how we can build a great
and cool applications using
Dart and Firebase
and how it can be
so much productive with them.
So let's start with me and Dart,
Why I do love Dart so much.
Dart makes me so much
productive and happy developer.
Because I often say that when
I'm writing Dart applications,
I just sit and write
a code which works.
That's awesome.
And also, I know
what's happening there.
I can't explain my
happiness with this
because, yeah, it works.
And I know why it
works and how it works,
and I can build a great
application with Dart.
But great application
need a backend.
And backend, there might
seem to be a lot of regs
in implementing backends.
Because, well, you have
to have a developer who
will implement that backend.
And there has to be
a lot of stuff to do.
So, for example, you
have to have a database.
So you have to set up a
database, select a database,
and do a lot of stuff
around a database.
Then you, for example,
want to have a file upload,
and you want to have some
users in your application.
So you have to implement a
login, registration, sign out.
And also, users
forget their password.
So you have to also implement
forget password function.
Then you would love to have an
anonymous user, [INAUDIBLE],
or you have to have some
hosting for your application.
And it's quite a lot of work if
you have a simple application.
a lot of work to do.
Well, and this
girl doesn't really
love implementing backends
because they are not
very much enjoyable to her
because there is no design
and colors at the backend.
And worse, she would
love to have a backend
without implementing backend.
What we can do with this?
Because this girl doesn't
love implementing backends,
she doesn't want to hire
a developer for that.
So what can we do?
Say hello to a service
called Firebase.
With Firebase, you can have a
lot of nice services, features.
You can have a realtime debase,
authentication, cloud storage,
hosting, and more.
And they are so
easy to implement.
And you can then focus on
much more important stuff.
And I have great news for you.
Because here, we
are at Dart summit.
We want to hear about Dart.
So you can use
Firebase with Dart
by using Firebase3 free package.
I implement it.
The Firebase3
package is a package
which is around JS interop.
You heard about how to
implement JS interop today.
So I'm using the new JS interop,
still like at the bottom layer.
And there is also a wrapper
around the JS interop
to provide you developers a
nicer and better developer API
and experience.
So what about the experience?
What's the better experience
with this wrapper?
Well, types.
I have to say I love types,
and I love using them.
So with this Firebase3
package, you can use types.
And you can benefit from it.
Like, for example, when
you're using code completion,
it's better for
documentation and so on.
Futures.
I love futures, especially
a single weight.
So lot of methods in
this Firebase3 package.
Write your own future,
and you can use it.
Streams.
We don't want to
implement some callbacks.
Like, streams are much
more nicer for this.
We can listen on streams.
We can filter them.
And then we can like-- we can
then do some functionality when
something even happens.
Methods.
You might have heard today
that there is some [? Hello ?]
[? interop. ?] So don't worry
about this because with this
Firebase3 package, you don't
have to care about and any
[? Hello ?] [? interop ?].
You just pause there
as parameter functions,
which are normal Dart functions
without any [? Hello ?]
[? interop. ?]
So that's all cool stuff,
but Jana, show us something,
show us some demo.
So let's go.
So I have a simple valve
application, which is kind of
[INAUDIBLE].
Here you can see that I
can just somehow sign in.
And I'm just having
here some notes.
So let's do first the sign in.
I have signed with Google.
So I will sign in.
There's some time-- because
I have the full screen.
And yes, now I'm
signed in with Google.
So this is a moment of
Firebase authentication.
And I'm now signed in.
Now again, see
that lots of notes
have-- I'm able to
create a new note,
or also I am able
to delete a note.
So let's start with
creating a new note.
So let's create a new note.
Dart summit is awesome.
And let's add the note.
And this [INAUDIBLE] Firebase.
They're in Firebase, and you
can see that the note appeared
immediately.
OK, like posting new notes,
so let's put there some image.
So I'll put there on image.
I have prepared my
image of my earrings
and-- to our Dart earrings.
And I have to write there
note text, so Dart earrings.
And let's post them there.
And they appeared
immediately again.
So I can refresh.
And you can see all of
the notes I did there.
So I'll show you another thing.
Because all the clients which
are connected to this web
page are able to post
their data when they
load with their Google login.
And then if they post
some note, the note
appears in all clients.
So I will do this
with my mobile phone.
So let's do that.
So I'll write here-- note,
summit, and let's take picture.
So I'll do a picture
of the screen.
And then I'll post it.
And note not posted yet.
So now I'm loading the image.
And now I'll post it.
And you can see it
appeared immediately.
[APPLAUSE]
This application is
simple, but it's full
implement in Dart and
Firebase using this library.
So let's get back
to my presentation.
So how you can build
an app like this?
Let's take a look.
So first thing, what
do you need to do know
is to find a Firebase3 package.
It's [INAUDIBLE].
So you can put it in
your [INAUDIBLE] file.
Then you can do the [INAUDIBLE].
You will get it.
And you can use it.
So then you have to import it.
And because as I already
said, the package
is like of wraparound interop.
You have to also include--
or you can't-- you have
to remember to include the
original JavaScript SDK
of Firebase to your HTML file
because it's a wraparound
interop.
So this is the import.
And then what we can use?
We can use all services
like real time database,
authentication, cloud
storage, and hosting.
So let's take a look
at realtime database.
Realtime database is
cloud-hosted database
which uses JSON distorted data.
So let's take a look how
we can structure our data.
Data are JSON, so you
can see here our notes.
So there is one note.
The note has some key
and some attribute.
And then let's take
look how can we load
the data to our application.
This is a code from my app.
And so we are listening
to some childAdded even.
So we put there on
our databaseRef,
we put onChildAdded
stream, and then
we start listen to that stream.
And if there aren't new data
added to our application,
new Note is added.
Then we get to the listen part.
We get the snapshot of the data.
Then we can get a value
from them, which is a Map.
And we can, for example, create
the new note and show it.
So that was simple.
Then we want to save the data.
Because when we
want to log data,
we have to also save
data, because we
need to have some data.
Saving is really simple.
You have your databaseRef.
Ref.
So you call push.
And with the push, you
put there some nice Dart
object so it can be
a list, or here you
can see a map, which has
been pushed to the server,
to the Firebase server.
And we are using a
[INAUDIBLE] because we
are having their futures.
So that was pretty simple.
We can do more stuff.
We can do also update, or we
can do update in transactions.
And we can also do
delete on the data.
And it's only with calling
some methods, which
are available because
of the Firebase.
And this took us about 15
minutes of implementation.
So let's take a look at
more on authentication.
Authentication,
because we want to have
some users in our application.
So we want to be able to log
in, log out, register, or so on.
And our application
used a Google login.
So we have there
a Google provider.
So how to do this?
Let's create new
GoogleAuthProvider,
and then call the methods
called signInWithPopup
with that provider
on our auth object.
And you are done.
And That's all.
You can also have
other providers.
There is for Twitter
GitHub, Facebook.
You can implement your own.
Or you can implement
an email provider
if you want to have the standard
email login, logout and so on.
Sometimes you want to
get your current user
in the application.
This is really simple.
Just call out currentUser.
And it will get the current
user in your application,
which is logged in.
And you can get the
image about the user.
Or you can get a name,
email address, and so on.
And also, I mentioned
a email provider.
If you want to implement for
example, the registration,
there is a method called
createUserWithEmalAndPassword,
which you will call
in your auth object.
And then the user is registered.
You will get the user, and you
can who displayed a profile
or whatever.
So authentication is
also really simple.
You are just calling some method
which does the stuff for you
on Firebase.
So let's say that this
took us five minutes.
Now let's take a look
at cloud storage.
Because sometimes we want to
be able to upload some files
to our server, which we
have in our application
because we had
their image upload.
So let's take a
look how to do this.
So first you need
to get the file.
So somehow you get the file.
And then you need to call
on your storage reference.
You need to call the put method.
But you need to also put
there a path to that file.
So you are calling
child with a file name.
And then you call
the method put,
which will upload a file
to the cloud storage.
And because we want
to use futures,
we will call future to use
as a single way and so on.
And then when we have
the image uploaded,
we can get the download
URL from the snapshot.
So again, cloud
storage, implementation
of this file upload was
really easy-- 10 minutes.
You can do more.
And you can find everything
in the documentation,
and it's really
easy to implement.
So I show you how
you could implement
application which uses Dart
and Firebase very fast.
Dart provides you nice
types, better productivity,
and nice API.
And Firebase provides you great
services which you can use,
and you don't have
to implement them.
And you can focus on much
more important stuff.
Dart and Firebase are so cool
and great partners together.
Maybe you want to ask
where you can get this.
So the library is
already on the pub,
so you can search
there for Firebase3.
You will find it there.
It's also on GitHub, so
you can download it easily.
And finally, I wanted to say you
can also build an app like this
using Dart and Firebase.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]